こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さん
ビーチボールというものはご存知でしょう
か
[音楽]
ビーチで遊ぶボールです
ビーチボールでよくあるサイズがなんか
このちっちゃいなんかこうやったりこうし
たりなんかこうしたなんかこうしたりする
のがビーチボールなんですけどもネットで
はですねなんと超巨大なビーツボールが
売ってたりするんですよ僕も最近動画で
使いましてそのピースも超でかいんでそれ
をこうグロスプレイで塗って
鉄球にしてドッキリしようみたいなんで
使ったんですけどもあまりにその鉄球が
大きすぎて私魅力を感じてしまいましたの
で
超特大ギガサイズのビーチボール2
メートル級のやつを
[音楽]
個準備しましたー思った直径2mだから
全部並べると2×20で40mの長さに
なります
俺より大きいビーチボールが20個私思っ
てしまいました186cmのはじめしゃ
ちょーより大きい2mのビーチボールを
たくさん買って3億円のお家の裏庭に
敷き詰めれば超巨大ビーチボール
ジャングルができるのかと思いまして
迷い込んでみたくありません皆さんビーチ
ボールの中で迷ったことないでしょうA私
は思ったビーチボールで迷ってみたい早速
超巨大なビーチボール全部膨らましていき
たいと思います
多分
朝までかかります
感じはあるんですけど
もう
俺より大きいねこれ20個やばいよ多分
地球の空気足りる
全然足りるちょっと頑張って電動の空気で
あるんで全部膨ら
ましていきたいと思うこの
スペースです
その時はその時付けていこうと思います
[音楽]
[拍手]
あでもなんか意外と速そう
[音楽]
落ち着け
よしよしよし
すごいよでもマジで
[音楽]
というわけでこれをあと19個あるので
早速全部膨らましていきたいと思います
一番
[音楽]
危ないこのこれでさ
イタリアンに移していますこれで
イタリアンについて
絶対ダメだ
[拍手]
皆さんも
部屋が埋まってしまいましたもう置けない
よねもう無理だね
多分半分ぐらい置けたと思うんですけども
さすがにこのサイズのボール膨らまして
たら部屋が埋まってしまいました今夜中で
暗いから明日明るくなってからボールを外
に出しつつ膨らましてバーンと袋に前が
大量の超巨大ビーチボールで埋まってる姿
ぜひご覧くださいおやすみ
おはようございます
朝ですというわけでシャッターの中にも
ボールを置けないのでできた分から
どんどん裏面に出していきたいと思います
[音楽]
全然埋まらない
結構入ってますわちょっと
オレンジの裏庭がでかすぎるものがあるの
で結果が膨らましたんですけども室内に
全部移動させたいと思いますでさすがに2
Mのものを部屋に入れるの扉が小さすぎて
無理なのでちょっと空気を抜いて全部室内
に移動して3億円のお家の中にある一番
大きい部屋に
ビーチボール入れ直したいと思います
[音楽]
結構空気抜けたのでこれで家の中に運べる
と思います
運び込みます
ここが多分
縮みで突破できなくてあーなるほど
で次の何かも階段ですね
無理っぽいかもちょっと抜くか
しら
こんだけ縮めてなんとかキツネに持って
くれました
頑張って
全部運び込みます
[音楽]
はじめさん
はいというわけでオレンジの中の一番
大きな部屋に入れてみたんですけどもどう
ですかこれ高さもう
怖いです3年から見てみようぜ結構34
メートルぐらいあるんでしたまで
相当遠いんですけども
ボールが同じ目線の高さまで来て
るっていう上の正面当たりそうだからはい
というわけでね
[音楽]
めっちゃきつかったです
俺に関しても昨日の夜からやってるんで
ここまでたどり着くのに約24時間かかり
ましたなんか
普通だったらこれ1個で楽しむもんなん
ですよ巨大なベンチボールだよなぁみたい
な
20個はないですね
非常にコスパが悪かったんですけどもでも
これ20個じゃないとこんな巨大ビーチ
ブル空間絶対できなかったのでもうまさに
奇跡の空間ですこれははいというわけで
せっかくこんな素敵な部屋二度と見れない
と思いますので超巨大ギガビーチボール
ツアーしていきたいと思います
ぜひ僕の部屋見てってくださいいきますよ
まずここが入り口になりますねどこここ
は
喜ぶぞこれを
[音楽]
超えるとお邪魔します見てここまであの
エントランスというか
すごくない天井はちょっと低いなってて
邪魔だっていう時の普通の撮っていただい
て大丈夫なのではいいやー
ほら
すごいすごいすごいここがローカってこと
ですねはいはいはいこの
廊下を超えるとはいはい
狭い奥にも生きるって感じですねこれ
無理やりすごい無理やり行く
ここは持っていくでしょ
[音楽]
なるほどここを通るとキッチンがあると
いうものキッチンになります
[音楽]
はいというわけでせっかくこんな素敵な
部屋ができたということでちょっと
鬼ごっこしてみない鬼ごっこっていうか
勝てるようにみたいな隠れんぼチップの
出したらめちゃくちゃ面白いと思うんです
けどもちょっとやってみようぜやり
ましょうというわけでスペシャルゲスト
[音楽]
どうこれいやすごいすけどバイトサボった
らしいなバイトサボりましたせっかくだ
から3人でさちょっと隠れ鬼みたいのして
みんな
しちゃいますしちゃいましょうしちゃい
ましょうよしじゃあ健介にでお前マジ
ぶっ殺すから呼び捨てろ最初俺が鬼です
みんなくれてね
30秒
用意
スタート123
もういい行きますね
良い
スタート
いやいや
むずむずむずむず
えぐい
えぐいってこれもう隠れてるとしたら絶対
低いところな気がするんだよ
やばいやばいやばい
[音楽]
よしよしまず1人目あとはどこ行ったどこ
行った
どこ行った
[音楽]
え
っ
帰っていい
あいたいたいたい
というわけではじめしゃちょータイムの1
分18秒でしたいや早い結構早い20秒
数えます行きます
スタートよしよしよし最速狙っていく
いないじゃん
言ったよおい馬鹿
見て
3分6秒ですねよし
どうでした
最初はじめさん見つけたんですけど
押されて
怖い怖い
触れてないから
見つけたそれは良かったじゃないですか
問題は健介さんなんですけど
見つけたのに
ボールをしてきてなかったことになったん
ですよ言ってるんですけど
髪の毛の魚使ってやばくない
けども
というわけで最後のサインザ健介さんです
お願いしますお願いしますそれでは行き
ますあと
さあ
行くよこれね
わかってるよ俺
自分が
隙間に足元が見えていたのでこう足元を
探していくんですね今ここの枠にはいませ
んこっちの国はどうかなってとりあえず見
てみましょう
こことかね大事ないね
しっかりと確認して1分経ちました
だが
こっちの角もしっかりと見ていきましょう
はいいませんと
うんこれガチでいないねああいたねそこに
[音楽]